welcome back to cbs morning some of the
most innocent victims of the war in
ukraine have only just been born
you were looking at some of the hundreds
of infants born to ukrainian surrogates
who are now trapped by the fighting
there kept away from their biological
parents who are helpless to keep them
safe as they anxiously watch the war
from other countries
charlie dagetta spoke with the nurses
keeping these little babies alive and
with a couple who decided they just
couldn't wait any longer
they range in age from just a few days
old to five months 21 temporarily
stranded surrogate babies orphaned for
now by the war raging above this
makeshift basement bomb shelter but not
abandoned looked after by an exhausted
team of dedicated nurses like antonina
yuffimovich are you getting enough rest
you look very stressed
our rest is no more than 30 minutes or
an hour we can't take more time a lot of
babies crying
they get a half an hour an hour of sleep
at a time
[Music]
that's all the time
day and night
[Music]
ukraine is a global leader in surrogacy
when the war broke out it became too
dangerous for the biological parents to
come get them the growing families
charity estimates as many as 800 couples
are waiting for their babies including
those from america
standing century outside we find chief
doctor igor pachanoga not in scrubs but
combat fatigues
we're in a war he explains what are you
telling the parents
in
he says what is happening here the
people are dying children are dying too
not just soldiers but also children
mothers
sisters
i think he's hungry hecka and gerhart
gotcha from bavaria germany decided the
risks of traveling into an active war
zone outweighed the risks of leaving
leonard in one that's why you came we
have no electricity no water
that's very dangerous for our baby
normal
when now
later it's dangerous it's more dangerous
you thought let's go and get there now
yes
the rest of the newborns remain safe for
now but as the war worsens and advancing
russian artillery strikes the capital
how safe and for how long
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta kiev
ukraine
oh man and with 21 babies you know
there's always somebody crying i just
never thought about that part of the war
there's so many layers that you don't
even think about that effect affect
different people that's it it's a
reminder that the ripple effect of war
has a multi-generational impact on the
people that are fighting it also just
how connected we are yeah surrogates
from all over the world imagine the
first five months of your life that's
the oldest baby there in the basement
under fluorescent lights no leaves no
sunlight it's
it's insatiation can you get and we all
know how important that is they're doing
the best they can i hope that nurse gets
some relief yeah the only silver lining
is that the babies have no idea what is
going on what's going on no yeah